so compliance rolls out what is it next
week okay and how are you feeling about
the release are you excited we're just
talking about that and we're really
excited about the movie I'm really proud
of it
the reactions to it have been somewhat
polarized you know people I think
critically sort of you know really love
the film and like you know the
filmmaking acting and everything and
some people are you know sort of up in
arms about the contents and things like
that so it's it's a we're really excited
we're just curious about what the sort
of reaction is going to be you know but
I think it's positive in the sense now
that people have an idea of what the
content actually is versus going into it
blind so hopefully people will do their
homework and their research before you
know going in and thinking that it's a
yes about middle America and that's
bigger and it's nicer to now that it's
just like at least people are talking
about it you know somebody's come and go
and you don't remember them to it I mean
it's after you see them so at least
before our talking about it sure in
light of the article that the the movie
is is somewhat based on and also in
light of what's happened in the last 10
years where things have been exposed
that we thought were fine does this make
you question authority in your own lives
we've all been taught to be good people
good citizens follow the leader but how
does this make you now look at what is
sort of shown as the right way to do
things does it make you slightly
questioned before tea I think that it
helps you in the sense to kind of
develop your own moral code and kind of
stick to something similar to that in
every situation and you know I think
that it helps to kind of have a base and
a foundation of what you know is right
and not to stray too far away from that
I think those of us that already
question authority or have since our
youth know so do you always well yeah we
all you know I I mean I come with from a
somewhat you know Catholic background
and and you know I grew up in America
and there's there's just things about
law and order that you obey and things
that you don't even realize you know
even if you you consciously you know
reject Authority that you sort of like
bow down to but I would say that
we all sort of have a curiosity about
how these people could have done what
they did you know in the situation and
we'd like to all think that that's not
us you know even all those of us that
made it but you know I think with work
gets sort of broken down a little bit of
that it could quite possibly be any of
us given it you know in that situation
you never know quite what you might do
right now Mary people came in the door
before one person finally said this is
enough yeah and I was just like I was
just in Michigan with Michael Moore at
his film festival and he was just he was
just going on about it you know some
people walked out of the movie and he
was like well they just don't they don't
want to deal with the fact that they're
sheep and that they filed down to
Authority for the last ten years in this
country you know since 9/11 with all
these wars and all this things and of
course he's framing it in that way and
he sort of fit his paradigm but in a way
it's kind of true we've all sort of
ceded some you know degree of
responsibility and bowed down to
Authority in the last 10 years in this
country and you know it's maybe not
surprised that the actual events that
this is based on have taken place in
this period of time sure
dreama for you some of the scenes were
you know probably difficult for an
actress to do especially given what you
were supposed to wear I know there was
an exit away exactly right the apron as
far as you know maybe parameters on the
set did you have certain requests I know
Lindsay Lohan was asked recently TMZ
about her scene and she wanted everyone
to sort of be in their underwear and so
she could feel comfortable was there any
type of well Lindsay Lohan I have a lot
um no I you know I mean of course I
initially you know when I started acting
and realized that this is what I wanted
to do for the rest of my life was kind
of anti nudity in the sense that I never
wanted to be googled or sort of looked
at that way which is why this actual
situation in the content of this film
spoke to me because it wasn't like that
and well you know I mean obviously the
issue spoke to me but I thought it was a
better way to do it
so um you know Craig and I had a lot of
conversations about it and I felt very
comfortable with him and you know that
we were just kind of like a little
family we had a lot of night shoots we
were exhausted and you know we had a lot
of delirious jokes you know and we felt
very comfortable and you know uh yeah I
felt I felt okay and I didn't make
anyone strip down to their underwear cuz
we were in a warehouse in Brooklyn and
it was very cold oh that would have been
rude and lastly you talk about career
and longevity it seems like in LA the
secret to a long career is keeping a
good mental attitude to weather the ups
and downs of the business what do you do
to keep that mindset it's not always
easy and I've been here a lot longer
than then dreama has just because I'm
older but uh I've been here a year but
yeah yeah but I mean you know um I mean
I've been on earth much longer than you
know that's not but uh I think that yeah
I think that there's a sort of attitude
that you write the narrative of your own
life and you sort of can write the
narrative of your own career there are
going to be external circumstances that
you don't control there's jobs that I'm
not going to get offered you know the
roles that Tom Cruise gets offered you
know and I know that and I recognize
that even though sometimes on a couch on
a couch I need to go crazy but uh you
know I I still think that I have
consistently worked over a period now of
almost 20 I mean 18 years fourteen years
in LA and it's only because ever since I
was a child I said well this is what I'm
going to do and I never deviated from
that and so even if I have a year where
I don't work I will it'll come back
again
you know ya know whether those storms
and as I get older and I know that
they're coming
then I it's easier to weather them the
more that I've been through them yeah I
think it's also just about like um
having some control about what projects
you pick and let into your life you know
I think it's a
navigating that ship and making sure
that you're on a trajectory that will
have the same end result that you hope
and yeah I tried very hard to only be a
part of projects that you know I think
are cool and you know thank you me
we've both been lucky that way to do
things that we actually would I mean at
a point in a career when we weren't
necessarily able to choose what we were
doing we both have done things that we
would choose to do yeah
thank you cool thanks thanks you guys